-I had a joke
where the punchline was
"Ibiza."
Didn't land.
Then I opined,
maybe it didn't land
because I didn't say
"I-bith-a."
Many of you said
the bigger problem
was the way I said
"Ibiza" made it sound like
I said "a pizza."
Someone wrote, "The worst thing
about watching 'Corrections'
in an area
with bad internet connectivity
is I can't always
immediately tell
when the video is buffering
or if Seth is holding for the
laughs that will never come."
Hurtful.
I hope broadband
never comes to where you live.
Well, it happened. The crew has
started a "Corrections" pool.
There is now a weekly
"Corrections" picture,
a series of boxes
like a Super Bowl pool,
and everyone picks a box.
And then after all
the boxes have names,
they randomly assign
the numbers.
There's a minutes column
and a seconds column.
So if corrections
ends up at 17:13,
it would be a seven,
and three would be the payoff.
Our associate director,
Amy Mancini,
does the official time.
And here's how it's changed
"Corrections" for me.
The second it ends,
I watch Kenny Coyle
poring over the boxes
like a guy who owns his bookie
$1 million.
Just ripping it up,
being like,
"[Bleep] Animal Flubs
[bleep] me!
I was right on time
and then the [bleep] Flubs."
Paul won last week.
Paul is the cameraman
who stands next to Buck,
and he used his winnings
on the most beautiful
noise-canceling headphones.
Headphones I assumed
he was already wearing
based on the lack of laughs
I was getting from ol' Paul.
We talked about the lack of
elevated debate in Congress
and how people
are talking in a way
they didn't used
to talk before,
and I compared it
to the Lincoln-Douglas debates,
and someone said, "Bad choice.
Racial slurs were used
in the Lincoln-Douglas debates."
Let me guess, Douglas?
I was very proud of my
oubliette joke last week.
Many of you asked if my mom,
a former middle school
French teacher,
had enjoyed it
and I did give her a heads up.
I said, "When you
watch 'Corrections' this week,
there's a joke
I put in just for you."
And then yesterday,
I called home
and I was talking to my mom
and I said, "Did you like
the oubliette joke?"
And she said,
"I don't think I saw it yet."
And then my dad
from the background, said,
"We saw it yesterday."
And then she said,
"Oh, yeah. It was great."
Literally a day later,
and she already oubli-ate.
We had a joke about a teenager
TP-ing my house
and someone said,
"That's not a teenager."
They also then pointed out
he wasn't a teenager
last week either...
...when he was working
at a carnival.
And this is the burn
when you're
the 12:30 show on NBC.
They won't --
not only will they not license
a photo of a real-looking
teenager for us,
we got to use the 27-year-old
more than once.
Meanwhile, they shut down
Fifth Avenue
so that Jimmy
could do a pre-tape with BTS.
"You can't give me a picture
of a 14-year-old?"
"We can't do it."
As someone else has said,
I think we have used Devin.
Devin is the name of our
28-year-old teenager.
We've used him before,
so we're going to go back
through the archives
and see how many times
we've used him.
Oh, we talked about --
Sal wrote about how
the Ohio GOP was trying to
overturn the voters' decision
in regards to a woman's
right to an abortion,
and he cited Marbury v. Madison.
And then someone said,
"That actually wouldn't apply.
That is only a federal ruling,
so that would not apply
to a state ruling in Ohio."
Which just proves what I've been
saying for a long time,
which is, Sal's dumb as [bleep].
You said Scooby-Doo
couldn't pull the mask off
because he lacks
opposable thumbs.
That is a very fair point.
I think we all watch that show
for its sense of accuracy.
Because dogs, of course,
can have a very acute
sense of danger,
and when a dog senses danger,
it will often say, "Ruh-roh."
I was told my Shaggy --
and again, I had some bad --
I had some janky impressions
this week.
I had a cold.
I saw my Shaggy sounded like
Werner Herzog,
which it does not,
but I wish it did.
[ As Werner Herzog ]
"Once again, Scooby...
...we find ourselves in
an unfortunate situation.
Hearts full of terror,
bellies empty of a pizza pie.
Our terror makes us run,
our feet moving
as fast as we can,
and yet we stay in one place
as they fail to find purchase.
In times like this, Scoobs...
...that one can only turn
to a solitary word --
zoinks!"
-Oh, we made a joke
about Don Jr.
looking like he was about
to get a colonoscopy.
Someone said, "You know,
that's very funny,
but you should use your platform
to stress the importance
of getting a colonoscopy."
So...
if you were on the fence...
...and needed to
hear that from me
in the body of "Corrections,"
maybe get everything
checked out.
Don Jr. said his dad could
see things other people can't.
Our joke was, "Like three ghosts
every Christmas Eve."
Many of you said that Scrooge
was actually visited
by four spirits,
counting Jacob Marley and...
The joke, I will say, three --
The joke just worked better
with three.
You know, because the book
has the famous line,
"You will be haunted
by three spirits."
So I think that's why
we did the joke that way.
But I will say, jackals
were a huge problem
for Dickens as well.
And there were two
versions of each of his books.
Like this is "A Christmas Carol:
Jack Addiction."
"Jack Edition," excuse me.
Either Jacks is what --
jackals were called
Jacks in 1850s England.
Or more likely, I didn't --
I didn't proofread
my email to Ellen.
Definitely picks it up.
I was like, "No, [bleep], what?
Well, okay."
So this is the Jackal Edition...
...of "A Christmas Carol."
Because again, it was --
jackals, you know,
they've existed.
It didn't just start with me.
"'That is no light
part of my penance,'
pursued the ghost.
'I am here tonight to warn you
that you have yet a chance
and hope of escaping my fate,
a chance and hope
of my procuring, Ebenezer.'
'You were always a good
friend to me,' said Scrooge.
'Thank'ee.
You will be haunted,'
resumed the ghost,
'by three spirits.'
Scrooge's countenance
fell almost as low
as the ghost's had done.
'When you say three,'
asked Scrooge,
'are you counting yourself?'
Marley paused,
confused by the query.
'What?' he asked.
'It's just,' said Scrooge,
'technically, you're also
a spirit who's haunting me,
so I just want to know if I
should count you in my three.'
'I don't count,' said Marley.
'It's three starting now.'
'So four total?' asked Scrooge.
'It doesn't matter,'
said Marley,
getting frustrated by Scrooge's
pedantic attention to detail.
'It matters to me,'
said Scrooge.
'Fine, you'll be visited
by three spirits,
four if you count me,'
said Marley.
'See?' said Scrooge
with a self-satisfied look.
'That wasn't so hard.'
Marley collapsed into a chair
and considered calling
the whole thing off.
Even if the ghost
did help teach his friend
the true meaning
of Christmas,
they were never going to
change the fact
that he was a [bleep] jackal."
Who do you think Trump's
Jacob Marley would be?
Roy Cohn, right?
That's who I feel like
who's going to visit him.
Mine's definitely
going to be Shoemaker.
He knows it, too.
Like, sometimes I'll be at
my desk, I'll just look up.
He'll be in the doorway,
eating an apple,
being like, "You think
I'm irritating now?"
"And I'm not bringing
three other ghosts.
It's just going to be me
in different wigs."
You dock boats.
You don't park them.
And I assure you, the writer
who made that mistake
will be getting his pay parked.
Our...
[ Laughter ]
Hey, our YouTube videos
are not available in Canada.
And a lot of Canadians --
This is a recent development.
A lot of Canadians
have been asking,
"Did we do something
to offend you?"
Ryan Reynolds.
I should have been Deadpool.
We actually don't know
why it happened,
and we're looking into it.
We did not do it on purpose.
It was not a choice we made,
but we did make sure you could
still enjoy "Corrections."
I said,
Randy 'Macho Man' Savage."
I was told it's
"Macho Man Randy Savage."
I was also told
I have a terrible
Macho Man Randy Savage
impression.
Well, joke's on you.
I was doing
Randy "Macho Man" Savage.
And that's how he sounds.
Oh, but his hand can do that?
Okay.
I did a phone gag last week.
If you missed it, it will be on
the "Best of Corrections" DVD.
Someone wrote in and said,
"Assuming that is a Western
Electric Model 500 telephone,
which it appears to be,
the ring sound effect played
is entirely wrong.
Not only is the Model 500's ring
much higher-pitched,
it's also dual tone."
So it's official.
There's [bleep]
phone jackals now.
A lot of you said the problem
with the joke, too,
is that I took a call.
The phone wasn't plugged in.
This is my cell.
Oh, sorry.
This isn't my cell phone.
"Corrections" is a cell
of my own making.
A prison.
Hey, we're going to throw --
because some of you
have been asking,
we're going to
throw the PO box back up.
Don't use it to
send dumb [bleep]
I can show to pad
the length of "Corrections."
That's not what it's for.
What?
What do you mean
I have to be done in 15 seconds?
Not my [bleep] problem, Kenny.
It's not my [bleep] problem
you're in the hole.
It's not my [bleep] problem!
That's why --
Uh, see me next week.